nous sommes le 21 juillet 1906 le
capitaine alfred dreyfus est réhabilité
dans l'armée française la fin d'une
injustice une véritable machination
judiciaire dont a été victime le
militaire ce polytechnicien et artilleur
de confession juive s'est battu durant
douze ans pour faire éclater la vérité
c'était quelqu'un de complètement
introverti complètement inhibé quelqu'un
qui était un scientifique
polytechnicien et qui partait du
principe que l'émotion n'avait pas sa
place dans la discussion et que seule la
raison avait sa place quand on voit ces
deux photos là en fait sont deux photos
qui sont prises à quelques années
d'écart là il est lieutenant de bande là
il est capitaine trois bandes en fait
c'est exactement la même photo il a la
même expression la même attitude
exactement la même manière de tenir son
son sa tête par rapport à ses épaules
ses photographies font partie des 600
documents à découvrir au musée dreyfus a
mais dans un établissement dédié à la
faire avec en perspective les destins
liés d'emile zola et d'alfred dreyfus
ses deux enfants de la république
le jeune italien zola puis de l'autre
côté l'israélite comme on disait à
l'époque alfred dreyfus qui va devenir
un militaire qui était amené
probablement à avoir le plus haut grade
possible et peut-être même plus que ce à
quoi il a eu une carrière absolument
somptueuse l affaire dreyfus un moment
essentiel dans l'histoire de france avec
des questions autour de l'antisémitisme
et du racisme des sujets toujours
d'actualité on voit des images
racistes xénophobes et antisémites et de
voir que le slogan de l'époque c'est la
france aux français qui est un slogan
qui existent encore on le voit sur
beaucoup de murs c'était le sous titre
du journal antisémite la libre parole et
ça a été le principal slogan de quelques
partis politiques pendant pas mal de
temps et encore aujourd'hui à côté de la
maison zola le musée dreyfus a pris
place un hommage rendu pour l'éternité à
emile zola et à alfred dreyfus dans les
yvelines à mes dents